yo what's up everybody we do win another
round this is round trace in the epic
tournaments cutting these guys using
sure honey I've gone and gotten third
place doce times doce totally means two
guys don't question my Spanish toast it
means to just you know doce means 12
that's why they do say means to I said
don't question my Spanish and then what
do you do you question my Spanish I see
I see cuatro Cinco yes I see it I see it
don't know what I'd yes okay okay
everybody calm down Carmina I'm gonna
have to expose some Latin knowledge at
y'all if you'll calm down I relax outfit
either so me oh my god a hit a virus I
have not gone I've gotten some feet
power up other than that I've gotten
zero here you oops still no power ups
yeah I it looks like oh there's a fight
going on over there no just punched
somebody to get rid of it I know of it
other than that yes it's forever oh my
gosh you got a virus Oh screw this oh oh
oh uh uh I'll blow yet now that's nice
noise oh my gosh he's loud died I'm
known for my loudness iont to see you it
this stupid virus sucks I mean you're
known for aging oh I just killed myself
nice
oh I killed myself okay that's the only
way I get known by raging it's a good
way to get regions good known oh that's
very positive headsets cuz I what I meet
you broken like three or four haven't
you good play from raging yeah Wow well
Rome at the wall oh my gosh yeah I don't
raise your heart that's an expensive
head saying you just threw it at the
wall big like what headset would you
throw out the wall uh turtle beach x
12-in x 11 oh well but i probably just
try not to throw stuff at all I try
doesn't work oh gosh it doesn't work
like 12 hits them why like done for well
boat that's why you don't talk against
the wall I've almost broken my wrist oh
that's good watch the door oh that's
good too wait weren't you wait oh crap
crap crap crap kill myself we get that
you would not get that you were not what
what we're talking about oh no what are
we talking about we're fighting out
screw you uh-oh someone's punching me
who can't touch this even though like
night and I haven't kind of kill stop
punching may not it oh gosh move oh yeah
I killed you I backed up into TT
explosion time be like oh we killed each
other nice i gotta kill ha we gotta kill
oh really really hell are you gonna give
me your disease disease a some hiv/aids
in there No Oh screw you i can't see
when you're placing that crap thanks for
all the stuff dude we're all you big boy
I'm by E oh crap oh crap where's worst
place you get
good to freak em with it oh ah there you
go take that disease yeah give them the
maids dang it dang oh you placed into
you oh wow did I die hi dad made zero
sense you know you i'm getting all my
stuff back oh I punch him and he doesn't
forget experience it hell I can't even
sprint i'ma and I don't only on with it
like what the heck eyes I am I many life
like 0 gives your lives even possible I
can't even see anything oh that's ENT oh
hey come back here come back here Oscar
you I'll screw you too big boy doesn't
make sense I was in the corner and I
died oh that's it oh hello hello back it
up back it up big boys everyone just I'm
just calm down yeah I got him ha oh I'll
screw this do you have super blast I'm
bad Noah's so you got like something
alright well like I just got all of your
uh explosion powers tell your power-ups
up oh that's what I'm talking about no
no you stupid taking all my goods I was
I was going taking I was gonna take all
those goods and then everyone just stole
it oh I just got killed nice I was gonna
take all the stuffs
okay so bummed are they on the bottom
nice i'm determined to get first this
round are you really joined super dude
were determined maybe not that
determined by I'm determined why he got
like second wow what I was not even
there that that bomb delay was way too
hardcore i well did I just get third
again yeah okay turn three times in a
row nice like see guys I think there's
gonna be one more game guys so uh every
one of my videos expect one more game
yeah he's out yeah yeah yo what's up
guys we got another match going on and
assignments with me mad Luigi prestige
two dimensions that's two dimensions and
DJ 3000 and it's only three person since
we lost a few people in the tournament
buddy same three thousand at 30,000
sorry I I were the first time I saw your
name Ivan like 30,000 obvious we have a
random boy and I noticed 30,000 no we're
just everyone says 3,000 all right so
there's everyone so we got DJs in that
corner I think two DS over here and then
we have I can't tell who someone's right
there random boy is across from me and
he's just doing suffer 02 power-ups
first text bomb explosion that's when
parting out one I got to power-ups get
on my level I don't want to go back to
local 02 but i'm not on level another
power up Wow oh I but their ball day two
of them have been bombed sizes so I'm
gonna end up killing myself Oh another
bomb sighs guys I have another problem
size per hour up you I have all the bomb
you gotta just kill myself you know I
got so much bomb delay so your bombs go
off instantly and my bombs or just nukes
there's this random guy likes crouching
but the Reign of God the last one he
just chased his ran or any sick was
fuckles and like you wouldn't even like
blow anything up oh my gosh the explode
was in yourself the explosion of this
bomb no I hate you I'm solo kill myself
yay any say I never hope is lost the
explosion of this bomb his mess oh crap
I got a huge bounce I'd now yeah he
bombed delay oh my freaking gosh I could
you would have got the pair up sat i'll
head as well if I could have another
bomb this if I could have like any other
path and I fought on top of a virus if I
could have any other bomb it would be
helpful as crap dimensions like any
other power up but I don't out of my
life how do you over here lucky aw crap
and then I myself cuz my bomb range or
just you huh oh I killed myself I just
killed myself and never have a look
yourself
I was able that guy had a virus i was
able to get back all my stuff before he
did crown slife ready guys cuz two
dimensions is a dick I have to send
anyone else from like not in your idea
with you someone else he's I have a
blood bond Kathie Lee if I could get rid
of this virus I would try helping you
out okay they're good Goodman is me I
don't think this guy has any sort of
bomb size at all so it's not like I'm
gonna have to worry about Oh Frick Frick
oh there he is there he is I get back
here get back here don't run away from
me oh oh i just got a plus two bombs
eyes did he kill himself on he killed
studies Oh screw you oh then I get glitz
in the bak blog hows great and life get
right now oh stop giving me the virus
you kid is that
this annoying kid has given me the virus
like 30 times Maibaum size is 700 this
guy has a big bombs hasn't screwed oh
yes I got out of it oh gosh someone so
we'll just go take take my virus screw
you oh my freaking gosh Oh Frick no no
no you know you don't oh my freaking
gosh I hate no no this boy okay I gave
him my virus escape I know I'm just
escaping screw this oh yeah same to
dimension oh my gosh i'm just gonna be
laying my bomb down long hallways cuz it
basically just nukes it just edges a
nuke now oh yeah well II think I can
also close to killing you with my bomb
scooty basically cuz it's a new key
kills everything hey striker 10 crab no
screw you go back oh I was in queue mode
oh no no oh my gosh okay I got three
bombs eyes back that's good oh did i get
plus one no I don't get it doesn't get
any bombs why is he punching me it's not
punching me like he doesn't matter you
there's no reason for the punch Oh screw
big boy i got i got sprint
I got spring big boy all Hawkins burn
for days just pick up the virus how long
a virus where'd you go where'd you oh
yes oh crap crap no no my goods my goods
all the goods oh my gosh final of
another ball let's go let's go let's go
what you're going to do what you gonna
do which can you that's what you can do
Oh Frick where'd you go there you are oh
[ __ ] this is good Oh Frick I killed
myself don't worry don't worry there was
a plus for bottom size next to me so I
have plus five bombs house right now not
a washout Oh Frick scream I'm oh yeah a
one haha first place alright guys I
think that was the last game so I hope
you all enjoyed this series whatever I
happen to upload it as and yeah this was
tons of fun and we're probably going to
do stuff like this in later dates
alright guys hope you enjoyed and peace
out you know ok guys we're gonna wrap up
a few guys had to go but we are still
here uh okay I'm gonna go ahead and read
off everything that we have here uh
coming in in last place with an
undetermined amount of points our mouse
and necro ah let's see going and next
the only player that has a it isn't tied
i think is DJ with seven points yeah
coming in right above DJ is two
dimensions and crazy horse with eight
points suppose abrazo even got that
fatigue boy I don't then with the high
points we have a blizzard
blizzard okay coming at ten points we
had an Alfa Laval prestige yeah Jake and
that's it for so many people pretend
points Wow I 11 points we have Leo hey
and at 12 coins or I think this second
place which way tie for second place any
noah james and kirkland instructor
duffer's 01 in a tie for first is mean
brecon oh ok ok one really the one that
suggested him to join this game hey boys
yes Jack you step back all right well
anyway guys hopefully you guys enjoyed
this crafty bomber tournament hopefully
you guys will want to see more and more
things like it it was a lot of fun to do
and we'll be sure to do more so check
out everybody's perspective they will
all be in description and I will see you
guys later thanks for watching and
goodbye yeah peace out of 1 i'll do my
own little logic yeah I don't worry you
probably didn't hear that ok bye alright
guys hope you enjoyed this little
turning we had we're actually going to
do another one this weekend and so I
hope you all enjoyed the collaboration
with these other youtubers if you did
make sure you comment below saying you
like it or if you want me to do more
solo stuff i'll do more solo stuff but
i'm definitely gonna do some of these
guys so be looking forward to that in
the future yeah
Oh